[Music]
that was so loud I think I'm like dead
on the inside and the outside
yeah you scream to the might recall
[Laughter]
liar I don't know what is recording
whatever welcome to the podcast
don't coffee into the night I'll call
for I need a coffee rule number one is
don't be nasty rule number two is don't
shop for wine the grocery store I have
wing deliver it to you this episode is
sponsored by wink guys we have a great
glass of wine it makes the moment better
so make wink get it alright wink gathers
your palate profile based on a quick
quiz you take and then they send you
wine they know you'll like right to your
front door alright right now guys go to
T ry winc that's tri wink calm sighs
tenderly get 20% of your first order
sorry $20 off your first order my
mistake and they will also cover the
shipping alright it's a great service
you don't have to stand in the wine
section in the grocery store not knowing
what the hell to do they just do all the
work and send you delicious wine $20 off
your first order it's sorry but why did
you just say wait at the beginning of a
podcast guys for those of you who lose
your keys in your wallets you'll also
like our next sponsor okay
it's tracker and their new tracker pixel
can I lose you are you know are you are
you guys always losing your stuff yes
well you don't have to anymore cuz
tracker pixel is a tiny coin size device
that you put on your belongings or dogs
but mostly belongings and you will never
lose it again because it tracks your
location and your items location with
your phone and it connects via GPS
okay really some [ __ ] smart device
can you not do that right now it's my
foot I know your foot needs to be over I
know I am you know like what's the
context guys it's a really awesome
device right now you don't have to worry
about losing your things again go to tra
ck our tracker comms last until you get
20% off any order I'm just gonna sit
back here for you to do that okay I'll
kill him
whoa why does it feel like it's been
eight years since we were here do you
like the big bear for my birthday I have
a sweater that says Big Bear that my god
got me and I'm wearing an empty backpack
crazy
my mom would she came over earlier today
she was like oh are you on your way out
the door and I was like no she's like oh
your backpack on it's like it doesn't it
yeah did you expect her not to be
wearing her backpack at home with
nothing in it my cake is wearing in the
big big baby York ink
yeah I can't get you her on one today
and by the way we didn't go to Big Red's
vegan she bought that off Amazon I don't
know what she's talking about
we went to make it was it was fantastic
we it was Jenna's birthday everyone wish
her happy birthday three one two three
you [ __ ] it up no she turned 31 last
Friday the 15th so happy birthday Ben
yeah I did it was the best it was very
relaxing and everything that I wanted to
do which was kick it in my sweatpants
and do nothing
we brought our new PC up with us and
probable PC that surprised me we brought
our Bret and surprise with a giant bear
which when I walked in like to the cabin
I thought your mom had put there no
labor it was a new festive stuffed
animal for Big Bear but it was just a
big bear was just a big bear break out
of I was like damn Lisa that's like she
really she went full out Big Bear did a
huge big bear here yeah
it was for me we brought it home it's on
the beanbag chair the
like to sit on him because they're like
baby sloths like you know a little
sloths they give them like a stuffed
animal they like cuddle with that's what
the dogs are like with the bear our dogs
are basically slots just a little dumber
give me one of them you're hogging them
all over there which one do you want
there's a blonde one and the crying give
me a child baby oh my god she's a flop
she's so sweet
you'll have to excuse the setup might
look a little different we have we're in
a bit of a little change right now
there's things that are changing in this
room so setting up the podcast is crazy
like the monitors are on the floor right
now in the table it's just it's crazy
because we switch it to game yeah we're
gaming like five days a week now so we
add videos we're getting a new table
we're getting my underarms everything's
gonna happen but right now it's just a
little bit [ __ ] so if you'll excuse it
Julian almost ragequit I almost range of
it before the podcast start cuz I'm I'm
literally I'm on the floor with the
mouse on the table above me and I'm
looking at the monitor on the floor like
that I look like a monkey using a
computer it's really functional
it's great don't do that sorry is that -
that it's louder for you than it is for
the audience I'm not gonna tell you
again rule number one is it I quit the
podcast the Julian podcast just yeah I
just talk to myself like a weird burps
throw up noise into the mic into the mic
burp throw up noises mic ink you know
that's actually that came out wrong
that's very wrong it was a joke I just
like making bird noises sometimes today
I burped the phrase no no no I was so
hurt someone burp the alphabet it was
like that but like I said a sentence
it's like in that logic Alessia car so I
was like who can relate and so we've
just been saying it like randomly yeah
it's a good song by the way but Julian
just started saying it
you burped it I feel like it's gonna
make me want to throw up my food but
okay go for it
so he did that I hate you I know I hate
me too I really do it was nasty huh I
need Jesus I don't have pocket cheese's
anymore I don't know where he went
okay so on our way home from big Mayer
Jenna was helping me like pass the time
driving by looking up our compatibility
he's already knowing astrological
websites astrological calm astrological
dot false information astrological
concise Julian 20% off JJ if you get a
glass of wine across deliver one glass
of wine to your door no I was like
looking it up cuz Julian Julian just
figured out recently that his parents
his mother's and Aries father's Virgo
and I was like that's why friends might
do like Virgo recognized ver gang we're
getting for life but my mom I discovered
is an early well it's okay let me just
preface everything that I'm gonna say
this progress as I understand astrology
is more of a guide than anything that
you know you know I I will say though
you know when I first like heard what
signs were and how they meant
everything's better personally I was
like all this [ __ ] it's all [ __ ]
like it's stupid don't waste my time
and the more Jenna's talked to me about
it the more I'm like okay this does I
mean some some of this stuff really
makes sense like as a guide
you know you not you are this person
because you were born just like traits
and you know it's more than a
coincidence I think that's what I
believe it's cool and so my mom is like
a very very early areas which Jenna says
if you're early in the sign I think I
could be wrong that means you're like
those personal traits yeah it's to do it
like your moon and your that kind of
stuff I don't know tell me Ronnie I'm
entertaining us for this cheese maybe
way more of an Aries if you can imagine
more of an Aries than I am like a bit of
she's a varies very this varies do that
again
she's varies oh damn cuz you're I do
there and your dad's a very winked I
wink yeah did you just segue again no no
I'm not there yet I just fake say it was
like a pump fake it was like it was like
good it's your friend you're like well
two for flinching yeah you uppercut in
the face like what you did to my video
that was I feel it video it was one of
my main channel videos and you were just
like it was like what the hell are you
got me the look at this cycle in your
finger whatever that's it badger Tom
alright so we looked up the
compatibility between burgers and areas
and we found something funny do you have
that page bookmark by the way yeah but
you took the mall fee and my phone's out
like six percent sorry these boxers I'm
going to read themselves you know don't
okay I'm so proud of I'm six um no but
we'll we were talking about we were
talking about how my mom is an Aries in
my dad is Virgo and it's very
interesting because you know thinking
back to when I was a kid watching them
interact my mom dad loved each other and
dad always had a plan yeah yes my dad
was that plan but they ended up dead
getting divorce and yeah you know I just
remember they were just on completely
different wavelengths in terms of like
their speed of life and it may it does
make sense like the Virgo being my dad
who needed to have things planned
couldn't just run a gun
whereas my mom was the most spontaneous
person ever met and still is which
earthquake are you moving like in that
state where like there hasn't been an
earthquake for a little while so I feel
like everything's an earthquake
now it's it's definitely an earthquake
of Julian it's Julian their earthquake
be lucky listen but I was reading this
to Julian in the car
and he was [ __ ] like peeing himself
laughter for me because some of its some
of it is like whatever but some of it's
funny these who can be so annoying to
each other but they might annoy everyone
around them like that's not only true in
real life but we also annoyed the entire
internet from putting ourselves on the
other
we're so annoying that we you know what
you guys yeah we're going to everyone
when you think of a partner who brings
out the best in you Aries and Virgo are
the worst possible match by the way this
this is astrology zodiac signs calm
there's a dash between all the words
like this one when I read this I had to
explain to Julian like usually when you
read these they're sort of like oh
here's your weaknesses and here's some
of your strengths and everything is very
like no matter what's going on like here
you love who you love and everything can
be fine you know it's always very like
it's fine everything's gonna be fine it
might not be like the most compatible
person in the world but that's fine
sometimes - yours is so [ __ ]
straightforward like just hammering that
we hate each other yeah okay the
downside of an Aries partner is there a
pulse of nature readiness to fight and
the tendency to lose their mind over
something that might not be that big of
a deal the possible downside of a Virgo
is hysteria and continuous never-ending
talks when they are not understood
completely - Julie it'll be like all
right I get it
let's be done talking I'm like no you
don't get it and then we'll talk for
like 20 more minutes yeah right that
sounds familiar it is a known fact that
Virgo likes things clean well in Aries
is an animal in their cage especially if
they're crazy enough to decide to live
together this could lead to endless
pointless fights because Aries will
never change their nature whose earth or
their priorities while Virgo will seem
like a crazy person screaming with
gloves and a huge ball of antiseptic
liquid in their hand the good thing is
that before they get to this stage of
their relationship they
probably find each other extremely
repellant and break up instead that was
that's like those funny yeah I look
honestly I love the annoying each other
so much that you're annoying other
people because you cited the example of
us out like on trips with removing this
and how in that oh sorry no no is the
discord message sorry I'm like so like
panicked that remember the time the
camera cut out really the audio cuts out
and like I don't we need a knock on you
[ __ ] would this this setup doesn't
fail us for the next couple times that
we have to deal with it ya know the part
where it's like you're so annoying
and you're not supposed to be together
that you annoy other people like that's
funny to me because us together with
Rome oh my god
she's had it right away stop it both of
you stop it
but um no we were talking after I was
like reading that or you're having a
laugh and stuff we're talking about how
like I'm not like completely ever go
like as much its first of all it's
hysterical to like yell out your sign
and then blame some annoying personality
joke but like I'm not a full Virgo like
virgos like things clean but like for me
it's more like I like things organized
but I don't care if there's a mess but
like if you put the spice back wrong in
the wrong spot I'll flip out like if
there's some clothes on the floor fine
if there's dishes fine but like if you
put a pair of pants where my shirts go I
will lose it yeah and you have lost but
I feel like that is very like specific
organizational yes but it's like the
feel like a true Virgo trait is like
everything needs to be clean but I'm not
quite all the way like the antiseptic
liquid and gloves thing yeah like I'll
need everything to be clean I just like
when things are organized like when
things have a place they have to go to
that place or else I'm gonna lose it
whereas Julian is an Aries and in it I
know you guys have seen his vlogs and
like cooking it's [ __ ] it's a
nightmare and it's like that everywhere
but like the mess doesn't but if the
mess bothered me sometimes we wouldn't
go it would be terrible
you know but it's also it's really hard
to ever be mad at you because it's
[ __ ] hysterical like if I didn't
think it was funny it would it would be
bad news for me really bad
but you think it's fine I'm trying to
think it was like something you did
earlier today like what the actual [ __ ]
is going on no it wasn't it was here in
the house when I saw you put something
somewhere and I'm like what the [ __ ]
like why actually why like I just like I
just yelled at him the other day because
I like sometimes I just don't understand
like when you do any cooks the
dishwasher in the sink are this far
apart from each other and so I'll put it
in the sink I'm like but at least put it
in the left side of this thing so it
doesn't go down no so I was like Julian
why can't you just put like the things
into the dishwasher like what he put but
you gotten so close why can't you just
open the door and put it in there why
they have to go in the sink and then I
was like don't put little stuff into the
like spoons and forks anything that can
go down the garbage disposal on the
right side cuz it can go down there and
you're like yep got it no problem that's
thing right now is full of forks there's
no floor no and then it'll go in there
don't run the dishwasher really oh I
think there's something in you
you mean the disposal yeah you know it's
sometimes you got to be sometimes here
you my theory is you attack your kitchen
you don't let it attack you you attack
first so it has the leg down you are
ahead of it you're calling the shots
okay you're dominating your kitchen
you're making your food you're not
letting the kitchen to take what's gonna
go in onto your plate that night that's
the most wonderful that kitchen has ever
been was when Julian got his wisdom
teeth out and you cooked really weak
yeah everything was clean I'm down if
you want to be I'm honestly I'll take my
Aries and get it out of the kitchen if
you want to be
like if you want to cook I don't know
I'm fine with that we've already talked
about that though it's only lasted like
maybe tops two days and then you're in
there that's true I always find it's
like all right two days later it's like
oh like running there and chug some more
juice out of the orange juice and the
cap in different places in the room and
the refrigerator is open yeah
that's only if it's in the daytime
because if it were nine times I would be
chugging wine that we got from wink
okay you know wink is a great service
guys you know what they do they select
wines thanks to many segways for one
podcast already I love you but what boy
sorry I'm good sorry I'm good guys wink
gets it okay that's why they start their
company to give you access to fantastic
ones around the world so you could have
more of those amazing moments that you
share wine with people and have great
memories okay
wink doesn't want you to have to go to
the store to buy bottles just based on
how they look which is always the wrong
way but it's always how I used to do it
you just go online take a quick pallet
profile quiz at Tri wink calm that's
wink with a c and they'll recommend
distinct interesting wines that actually
customize for you and ship them right to
your door there's no more time guessing
if you're gonna like a wine you're just
gonna like it that's how it works its
science guys all right we've had some
amazing wine slowed by wink and you
never have to even go to the store how
about that week everything we do now is
on an app okay
so a wink is no different they're gonna
send it to you alright you go to try
wink on that's t ry winc comm slash
annejulien you get twenty bucks off your
first order and they'll cover shipping
alright and also if it's a one a wine
bottle you don't like 100% satisfaction
guarantee so never pay bottle never pay
for a bottle that you don't enjoy thank
youing also here guys that you're always
losing your stuff and you know you're
sick of it the wallets the keys the
backpacks eight years ago tracker
changed everything and they released
their first tracking device I know
they've done it again with the new
tracker pixel the latest Bluetooth
device on the market this is going to
solve all of your lost item problems
okay it's like unbelievable
tiny this little device okay you put it
on your keys on your phone in your
wallet in your turning back I mean your
bed on your pet all right you put it on
the things that you lose or you don't
want to lose okay I have my on my drone
bag everywhere I go my drone case a my
backpack and my keys and you don't it's
like peace of mind you're traveling
maybe have to check a bag that has
important things in it you don't have to
worry you're gonna always know where
that bag is it's tiny alright so when
you lose an item that has a track of a
pixel attached use your smartphone and a
90 decibel alert will help you find it
in seconds even has a powerful LED light
to find it in the dark it lasts for a
long time right you know I actually
don't know the exact amount of time a
long time though yes really long time
when so and because tracker is part of
the largest crowd locating network in
the world you can find your item even if
it's miles away alright don't worry
about losing your things again go to
tracker we've got the tracker th e TR
ACK our comm slash Jenna Julie and get
20% off any order or click the link in
the description guys try it out I'm
tellin you won't be disappointed thank
you sponsors can hit your feet down now
it's very comfortable
alright so the next half of the podcast
is going to be people that we think
I think that anyways going back to the
before we do that like going back to our
compatibility I think that if I was a
little more Virgo II and you were a
little more Aerys II it would be really
trouble but like we're we're a little
bit like our signs but not completely
I think we're the chillest version of
our science yeah because I'm I know I'm
an Aries but I'm also like I get it like
I'm not crazy
yeah you're not crazy I'm not great you
know crazy
so we compiled the list each of us of
people who we think are above the law
girl totally above the law I'm kidding
so how did this start it was your vlog
great well yeah we were talking about
Lauren Taylor yeah so hot for food she
made uh it's a nacho cheese sauce but
it's like a Mac Mac skillet is what the
recipe is
dude and I kept saying like it's so good
like she should be above the law for
making that so people are like you
should make this a podcast like who do
you think should be above the law so
maybe some some of mine at least aren't
like above the law but there's they
should have certain privileges so I
wrote down who I think should be above
certain laws why don't you kick this off
okay baby
you have more than me so you can read a
couple of you are yeah well my first one
is Lauren Toyota yeah Lauren Toyota that
makes skillet recipe with the nacho
cheese is so [ __ ] delicious if you
are vegan and you have not tried it you
are doing yourself a disservice it's so
delicious it's really good I feel like
since her last name is Toyota she should
be able to always drive in the carpool
lane at all times regardless of who is
in her car it's a funny ladder break
she's above the law like if someone's
like woo excuse me ma'am you can't drive
in this personally yes I can't I am
Lauren Toyota here's my nacho cheese
[ __ ] she's has a nacho cheese with her
in the car where everywhere is that part
of the log ya know yeah it's probably
part of the law because she'll have to
have her license registration and
nationalities she pose she reaches her
full fist into the nitrous ease and
pulls out her license registration
dripping with nachos like thanks was
good you know
REE Drummond
oh my god by the way who just [ __ ]
notice that I exist I am dying on
Twitter someone tweeted a picture of me
in that hat which someone said to you
the other day it says I'm REE Drummond
so I'm going to sent that to the PIO box
a long time ago so I was wearing it and
someone took a screenshot of that video
tweeted it at REE Drummond like would
you want to wear this hat or do you
think you could pull this off I was like
yeah I think I could pull it off you
tweet back with the winky face emotes
yes so then I tweeted I was like oh my
god mom's seen a picture of me I'm dying
and then she liked the tweet and I was
like I'm dead goodbye everybody
I love REE Drummond the Pioneer Woman
for those of you that have no idea what
that is where we're talking about it's a
food show on Food Network
she literally made her six-year-old son
an ice cream trough for his birthday
she's pretty legend yeah it's like okay
she brings the world joy and sometimes
unintentionally hilarious fashion right
yes Ted Todd team tater they wanna they
want a 6-foot ice cream truck for their
birthday so I'm gonna make chocolate
vanilla zoom we got syrup then we got
caramel this pocket strawberries we
train the whole show is a caricature of
it's that's a lot um
REE Drummond in my opinion is above the
law and that she should be able to punch
one person a year without consequences
and it will likely always be her husband
after he fails to tell her that he likes
her so weird yeah she has a couple
glasses of wine and then she's sitting
at the table that's my point
boy there's too many segues she's
sitting at the table with her husband
and she's had a couple of glasses of
wine and she's like it's cutting back
and forth they're talking about the food
or like how they meant it she's like do
you like me just out of nowhere she's
like me yeah she's like do you still
think that I'm pretty and you're like oh
man this is getting real yeah he's like
god damn it
camera community retailer pretty shuttle
he's like dude we have like five [ __ ]
kids together like mentally and
emotionally breakdown on care and they
didn't cut any though yeah no uh yeah
she should be above those in that she
can punch one person a year without
consulate I think that's fair that's
fairly good because you know she's not
gonna do it unless she like she's a
lovely quaint adorable woman if three
Drummond's allowed to punch one person a
year without consequences they deserved
it yeah and she doesn't look like she
could throw a very strong pillow fists
yeah pillow face Drummond I just love
the idea that she like who clearly is
just like trying her best at the
Internet right like she's got a Twitter
account yeah and she finds a someone
tweeted her a picture of this chick on
the internet wearing a hat that says I'm
REE Drummond she says no other questions
on her part yeah like why does that how
does a person have that hat and a grown
woman have that habit - and that she I
hate where you have this is i'm jenna
mourey I'd be like [ __ ] what is like
answers the question like yeah
is she a robot you think I don't know
maybe she is like one of those PR
companies running your Twitter ego oh no
no because they she one time tweeted
when you're all out of stuff to watch on
Netflix
that's worse than fresh hell or
something remember and I was like man
sister fresh hell fresh hell wow we're
in the culinary world I think Gordon
Ramsay what what is he above he isn't by
this law okay it's just a very
situational law again very specific
incident what is it
if out at any restaurant that's sorry if
out at a restaurant his or anyone else
in his party's meal is not up to his
standard the Ramsay standard he not only
has
the entire meal comped automatically but
he also gets to go into into the kitchen
right that in there and the rate and
possibly fire the cooks and chefs who
made that food causing a very
inconvenient and weird scene at the
moment but also bettering the restaurant
for the greater good of the yeah I had
one who also is allowed to charge
whatever he wants for anything in the
restaurants that he says literally
however much charge I had one similar to
that it was Dolly Parton should eat and
drink for free anytime anyplace yeah
that's good that's good
Dolly Parton isn't it true that char
organization buys more children's book
than in books than any other
organization in the world it's something
like she's wonderful dolly woods
wonderful she's just a [ __ ] she's a
legend thousand dollars a month I mean I
guess either their website and see
what's up yeah it's something like that
but sure her organization buys a lot of
children's books and gives them to kids
yeah I mean they're not gonna like brag
about being the best on their website
but I'm sure like what I just confirm
that's like that's a thing I just don't
know at that level but it's impressive
anyways right room she should be she
doesn't look like she eats and drinks a
ton I feel like she should be able to
eat and drink when she does whenever she
wants that's fair she was like a teeny
tiny little petite lady she's like hi
I'm Dolly Parton are like a sandwich I'm
like [ __ ] hell yeah yeah let me feed
you
yeah what do you want to drink what else
can I get you because it's Freddie for
you you don't part in am i scaring you
also have a diet doctor partner alright
my next one are you done Hugh Jackman
Hugh Jackman is allowed to work oh you
if you don't if you don't know about
that one you're definitely not going to
know about the next one
definitely this is questionable I might
argue with you Hugh Jackman is allowed
to work out at any gym anywhere forever
for free okay in fact the gym will shut
its doors to anyone while he gets the
Train iPhones currently correct his last
name to hack man okay he deserves to own
every single gym if he wants no also
because the iPhone corrects Jackman the
Hackman he deserves a Jackman emoji that
will be released with iOS 11 no no he
was also allowed to deadlift anything he
sees out in the world if your grandma's
walking down the street he might
deadlift her if anyone ever addresses
him as Wolverine or Logan in public he
has the right to deadlift that person
for however many reps he wants that's
okay he can also see any x-men movie in
theaters for free forever with a one
plus one ticket not plus two that's fine
all right
I just he's not allowed to shut down all
gyms yes no no he's for free and he can
deadlift whoever he wants but he's not
allowed to shut down Jim Hayes if if my
gym was closed because Hugh Jackman was
in there I'd go get the [ __ ] out no get
out deadly feud he said that I don't
care I'm dead listen bag I'm gonna get
in some dentists can deadlift everyone
and no one can deadlift him that doesn't
seem right at all what did he what did
what gives him the right
he was Wolverine is Hugh Jackman no I
don't care he hasn't done enough for me
to be like you're above the law degree
okay I guess you can and he gets the ax
moat with the moji with Ohio's 11 is
gonna be Hugh Jackman moji
looking forward to it does it look like
looks like him nice cool or good good
alright I mean you can have it thanks um
Tim Gunn was - yes my dad that's a good
one I should pick them I shouldn't have
to go through TSA at all he's immune
yeah he just walked through the air for
ya Tim Gunn for those who they don't
know he's at a show called Project
Runway I'm off you Parvez very [ __ ]
sick it's good he's he's the students or
the competitors mentors we never even
judges them he's literally just there to
help them and like build up their
confidence and self-esteem and give them
constructive criticism he's [ __ ]
wonderful
so it was a magical person I feel like
he should never have to ever take his
shoes off if he doesn't want to cuz
they're probably really expensive and
wonderful so good for him he's immune
from the TSA he's the best
like if Tim Gunn's walking up to the
airport we're all like yo he's good let
him on the plane that's Tim good mm-hmm
all right Justin Theroux this is just
your man crush list okay so maybe it is
maybe it is why is what is Justin a
thorough above the law for and why and
what is what does he get to do what are
his privileges Justin Theroux by Julie
insomnia Justin Theroux is above the law
because he's fantastic
okay he's an incredible actor okay
singer he's allowed to pet your dog
follow me on instagram Oh what if he
wants to pet your dog he is allowed no
matter if you give him permission or not
if he comes up to you and you were
feeling unsafe and he says I want to pet
your dog you were not allowed to say no
he will pay your dog you taking away
people's consent
just to pet dogs okay calm down what
about the dogs can say the dog will like
it he's allowed to stand on any table at
any restaurant and sing homeward bound
and everyone has to tip him no matter
where he is you know what time it is yes
he's also allowed to change any business
elevator music of any business Parker to
what really yeah I have Bruno Mars
should be allowed to curate all elevator
music in the entire honey yeah Justin
Theroux I was allowed to change any
businesses elevator music to the score
of leftovers without the building owners
permission I don't know it's okay I do
he's an actor
whoa he's also a guy in a person and
yeah fantastic but I mean it's not like
they're like Justin Theroux I was
allowed to pet anyone's dog at any time
like he's above a lot of laws he's
allowed to just stand and sing openly at
restaurants on tables and then you'd be
lucky if you got just yeah that's a lot
it's worth it
trust me have you ever seen Justin throw
alive on the table it's a good show to
Liz
all right I feel like the dog is okay
the dog thing petting all dogs in
elevator music I mean that score he
should be allowed to sing and stand on
all tables but we shouldn't have the
Tippin how about this you tips are
welcome okay necessary okay fair enough
okay he also can stream on anyways
Twitter
okay that's sick I would love Justin
Theroux to take over our Twitter oh yeah
can you tell them why you love him so
much he just the character he plays in
the leftovers is the best it Julie loves
after he's saying in that scene the
homeward bound scene he's just like I
thought all of them [ __ ] oh god
damnit man I wish that show wasn't over
yeah he sings homeward bound that that
episode for me was a powerful episode
though yeah it was the the purgatory
where he's like the secret agent no
spoilers whatever it's not a sport it's
kind of an isolated episode at this
point but it was a powerful episode for
me just the way they did and I really
loved it and the way it ended was just I
mean it almost brought me to tears I'm
not gonna lie okay next one mine yeah
you okay Joe Rogan
that was everything that I aspire to be
in life I love him he does everything
that he wants to [ __ ] he's the man I
think he should be allowed to swear on
air doing UFC fight like three times a
year and have no one get fined for it in
any context that's it that's so
appropriate that's allowed to say it
like at least three times whether it's
like HBO or like not a field like pay
per view or Fox Fox or anything he's
allowed to swear three times in any
context and say any bad word that he
wants without anyone getting each other
know what I like about that rule is
because you're limiting him to those
three words Squared's you know they're
gonna be really really well created oh
yeah yeah that's that's a really good
love for him to be above so like for
anytime like and we all have to just be
like oh damn there was one like no one's
allowed to get mad at him no no one is
allowed to like say anything like if
somebody's pissing him off he's like
what the [ __ ] was that like he's allowed
to just say that we have to be like
Danlos Joe
yeah that's one that's one too that's
damn this my god he uses alert on damn
okay cool
I think that's very it is fair right
yeah I do wouldn't you love ray and
they're just [ __ ] are you kidding me
and people with God would love it to UFC
would be smart to allow that okay
seth macfarlane know kind of knew it
he's like the actual idol I love him
he's my celebrity crush of all celebrity
crushes he should be above the DMV he
never has to go that's really fair
literally never has to go that's fair
yeah that's like really nice of you to
say yeah he just doesn't have to go so
he does how'd he get his license they
just mail it to him but how does the
updated picture they just take one off
Google that he likes how does the
updated signature he doesn't he doesn't
isn't house he refreshes driver of
course he doesn't have been yeah okay
cool that's fair I don't argue it
probably doesn't even drive himself that
much you know other people drive him
mm-hmm my next one Ryan Higa I've read
he tattoo well I did it first
[Music]
Ryan Higa has allowed to post a video on
anyone's channel on YouTube no questions
asked
that's not what I had
what's your right heel my right he going
was should be allowed to win all rec
league basketball games everyone should
have to lose him on purpose because he's
wonderful and deserves it I wanna watch
him play again though right dude he was
[ __ ] use really good yeah I mean it
inspired me for my basketball game
tomorrow but you know the other how he
might have to help me practice for your
basketball you really great that's the
collaboration waiting for him helping
you with you guys to ball game tomorrow
could be epic but but I have to lose to
him because that's he's above the law
never know if you train hard enough you
could win any basketball game tomorrow
alright no you're gonna okay I have
Giorgio tsoukalos agent okay it's not
it's not unreasonable okay yeah no it's
definitely not unreasonable um
he's know
privileges unreasonable he's made my
life fantastic so he's made by like so
great that's just sweeping statement I
love him um he should be granted access
to all the exclusive like ruins and
sites that they don't allow people
that's so he can stand around and say
huh aliens for his show as much as he
wants us to see that that benefits other
people like he's yeah he's not allowed
to like excavate stuff or like you know
yeah uh I don't know what's the word
that I'm looking for
look you can't do archaeology [ __ ] like
he can't like dig [ __ ] up but he's
allowed to go in places that other
people aren't so he can stand around so
he has access to special like like area
51 he could go he can go and just like
huh that's pretty dumb because you know
what he's gonna do there is gonna like
gather knowledge for the rest of the
world to know knowledge knowledge my
turn
yeah alright Chris Meloni oh my god how
did I not think a a detective Stabler
didn't he can do splits then all right
the law that he's above is that at any
time in his entire life he's allowed to
just be a regular real-life detective
and no one has to ask it see one soon
yeah thanks for like an hour yeah you
might be done yeah okay that's
incredible amazing I think all of our
Christopher Meloni fans out there will
genuinely appreciate that yeah like he's
allowed to show up at any crime scene
like this with nothing in his hand like
drunk if he wants to yes yes oh my god
alright that's really good okay
I have a share I feel like whenever she
tweets it should automatically go into
Twitter moments immediately every tweet
immediately in tournaments so Alex see
that's funny that's she's been [ __ ]
violent on Twitter yeah she's always fun
Jeff Probst oh why didn't I think of him
either
oh I'm killing myself right now ah the
wall that he is above that if there is
ever a collar blue shirt anywhere in the
world Jeff can have it for free because
it
percent looks better on him good he
should carry around like disposable tank
tops with him or something to give
people give me that bucket you know and
you can also go anywhere and say drop
your buffs and you have to drop
whatever's in your head like he just
walks into like a pinare drop your pots
everywhere god damn it Jeff
drop your boss no you also have to hit
the floor too let's get the lay down and
assume the position until he gives you a
new team oh my god and he goes he walks
through the Panera and makes everybody
sit with a new person and make friends
I can't wait oh survivor starts what's
your next alien form or okay and for I
have uh I have Rihanna right obviously
she is my other Idol she's above walking
with her own legs she shouldn't have to
walk for anything other than pure joy so
someone else walks for her no she should
be carried everywhere on a literal
throne if Rihanna doesn't want to walk
you shouldn't have to
Rihanna seems like the kind of girl that
just wanted to get carried everywhere so
I think that's fair I think that's worth
she's above she's above walking out of
anything other than happiness yeah like
she shouldn't have to walk to anywhere
ever
yeah that's fair she's Rihanna she's
she's next one she should be carried
okay probably will carry her
Rihanna volunteer to be her carer yeah I
will carry you I will carry you all the
time I can deadlift I'm good uh you had
you someone was Oh Hugh Jackman was
allowed to see movies I had RuPaul
should be allowed to use all copyright
in music for free in his shows and go to
concerts for free and see music movies
for free because RuPaul that's fair for
research that's fair right yeah
the copy written one of the nice I like
that welllike even for RuPaul's Drag
Race like he must run into copyright
problems at some point on that show yeah
like you can't use that song you have to
use this one like no they should be able
to use all copyright music on RuPaul's
Drag Race
there's no life a little bit easier yes
yes
fair enough I think that's a good rule
yeah it is right mm-hmm
Serena Williams can do whatever she
wants she won the Australian Open while
pregnant she can literally do whatever
she wants there's no like was there's no
limit that mashing directions she can
get away with murder
you can murder everyone it's honestly
it's it's welcomed what so you're saying
that serene Australian Open more
pregnant than murder me Serena Williams
is allowed to take 20:17 comments
literally yes Serena Williams can do and
will do whatever she wants forever know
what if you changed it to if you if you
write Serena Williams a 20-17 comment
she's allowed to literally carry it out
and have no consequences that's actually
nice that's nice like run me over with
your motorcycle and rewind my [ __ ] like
a VHS tape manually with your fingers I
see some of those on the twitch stream
and they like literally make me shudder
yeah they're codes they're also a weird
friend you got
I had Tait eggs because he's from
Rochester and he's like the coolest
thing we got from there so I think he
should be the honorary mayor of
Rochester forever even after he's dead
he's still there yeah okay
he's their guy her he's like our
figurehead he's like our Iron King the
king of Rochester King Diggs King Diggs
shall be referred to as King Diggs King
Diggs is the king of Rochester enough
how many more do you have just one oh
yeah one more Oh Calgon oh yeah because
we had like some double size binging
with babish the law babish is above the
law he if you don't know what his
channel is he recreates movie and TV
food too like such a perfect degree he
loves him and the amount of effort and
detail that goes into each episode is
like it's unheard of on YouTube in
addition to that he has a great eye for
cinematography so because of those
things he does never have to pay taxes
on food he buys oh that's a dope lens I
think that's fair I mean cuz it's
contributing to the content no you
should get all that food for free and
so he just goes to the grocery store he
just takes her every means yeah and then
walks out I like that yeah he's not
taking like an obscene amount of food
he's like I'm gonna make a video today
he's allowed to just take what he needs
yeah he's not allowed to like eat
everything for free out of the grocery
store he's putting it to good use he's
like taking these very obscure
ingredients making magic yeah okay cool
Demetri Martin is another one man what
hell yeah he's allowed to tell stand-up
comedy wherever he is and immediately
gets paid for it no matter what it's
[ __ ] amazing I would throw money you
have to I'd find whatever cash I could
find and just Harlan I've thrown my
money at him before really I went to
watch him live one time you didn't throw
any nice figurative money okay I was my
figurative you know that whole like take
our money I throw my money at you would
ever you go to a comedy show and you
just start [ __ ] Hocking chunks of
bills up there there's [ __ ] nickels
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] helping them in the
eye it's like what you do with a
stripper but like it's just someone else
that you like threw dimes and nickels
and a stripper
Oh would hurt yeah of course it would
hurt no I'm talking about like taking
stripper culture and just applying it to
anyone on a stage that you like but it
has to be more than once though yeah you
can throw like a full stack of money up
there if you throw a briefcase I love
you yeah just write your Bank info down
a piece of paper here's my paypal
password
oh my god all right my last one is uh
Sam Smith should be able to cry in
public as loudly as he want it wants and
we will hug and applaud him for hit
that's good yeah I would just cry with
him hell yeah I do I think your list was
good yeah you had people on there that I
totally like Chris Meloni I'm like
kicking myself yes
dan he is above the law well if you guys
think there are other people above the
law that we missed which I know there
are because we missed a lot of people
I'm sure leave them in the comments
below
yeah and what what you think their
privileges should be yeah yes
playing the game with us we want to hear
it cuz that you guys always make us
laugh so make us laugh some more now
ready go and be funny thank you guys for
hanging out we'll see you guys for
another episode next week dink it up
until then dink it up and
[Music]